this uh article from the daily caller my
friends over at the daily caller was
interesting to me about maryland
maryland schools guidelines claim kids
have a right to keep in-school gender
identities
private i was like huh that's
interesting so let's look at the article
first and then we'll get to exactly what
it says
and there's two components of this okay
there's one component which is that kids
are have the right to keep their
in-school ideas so how they identify in
school private separate from their
parents their parents don't have to know
that's number one we're gonna get into
that and the second one deals with
bathrooms
okay
so let's hold on that one let's start
with the gender identities let's read
maryland public school district asserts
kids have the right to keep their
in-school gender identities private from
parents the guidelines vow to quote
respect the right of students to keep
their gender identity or transgender
status private and confidential
including parents who do not affirm the
child's perceived gender identity
educators are told not to contact a
student's parent or guardian can you
imagine until they speak with the
student to ascertain the level of
support the student either receives or
anticipates receiving from home so you
send your kid to school
say your kid's in ninth grade i'm going
to make up a grade that kid has a
separate life at school has a separate
identity in the sense that maybe you
have a little boy that you know you sent
to school as a boy identifies as a girl
at school
and the school acknowledges that
treats that child like a girl does not
pick up the phone to call you first
talks to your child who is a minor last
i checked okay
child's tax dollars aren't going to fund
that education yours are as the parent
that child gets consulted
and then maybe maybe you get looped in
if you're supportive if they deem you as
supportive
interesting interesting way to spend
your tax dollars at that school
okay
let's continue staff members are
required to call transgender students by
their identified name and or pronouns
and to the extent possible school
personnel will make efforts to maintain
the confidentiality of the student's
transgender status the guidelines
specifically tell educators that unless
a parent you listening mom and dad
unless a parent affirms a student's new
identity
to continue to use the student's legal
name and pronouns when talking with
parents
so you see this game that's going on you
are in the dark and this particular
school this is the montgomery county
public school district their guidelines
unless you go along
you're just kept in the dark
right so you've got a kid that's growing
up with a whole identity you don't even
know about maybe among their friends
among their teachers among their
guidance counselor i remember once
talking to a guidance counselor in new
york that was very proud to tell me oh
yes i have students come to me and they
tell me you know about their
gender identity and um i don't tell
their parents because i don't know if
it's a safe space at home and i just
thought to myself wow you're doing your
job horribly
okay now remember i'm saying this all
but all of this stuff and having all
these conversations from the lens of
somebody who didn't only teach these
kids
but was a student advisor to these kids
and was a 9th and then 10th grade dean
to these kids i can tell you that this
would never happen
parents were looped in every single time
anything that involved something medical
that involved something that centered
around the health and wellness of that
child the parent was looped in
and i was quick to discover if there was
any issue at home you got to sift that
out too of course guidance counselors
get involved sometimes you never know
sometimes situation at home isn't ideal
they have to be looped in that's a
that's a parent right this is a child
you don't know child could be saying one
thing maybe that's not what's going on
at home at all these aren't adults these
are children
okay
i have a question yeah so what happens
if say a a child is um
getting backlash at home and you know
they don't want to share that well how
does it like what does the guidance
counselor do to like avoid the kid
getting hurt at home or like well at
some time at some point i mean if there
is legitimately an issue going on at
home where there's any violence in the
home or there's any abuse emotional or
otherwise in the home and the child
comes and vocalizes that then there's
usually a third party that's brought in
but oftentimes what it is now that you
see happening a lot is there's just a
different way to approach it like the
parents may not be supportive of their
third grader waking up one day and
saying oh i
my teacher read me a book about boys and
i'm i'm a boy you know they're not
supportive of that they don't think that
their third grader is able to make that
informed decision so they're not
supportive and now what you have is
teachers and administrators kind of
battling parents
and saying we're gonna shut you out but
of course if there's an issue of a
legitimate problem in the home where
that is not a safe home
i mean that should be looked into
regardless not just as it relates to
gender but across the board so at that
point you'd have a third party and i
always did that's why i kind of
introduced and said i always kind of
assess that situation it's very easy to
see the dynamic all you have to do is
sit children with their parents and you
can often assess that dynamic that's
going on you can bring a guidance
counselor in you can bring a third party
and you have a lot of tools at your
disposal but there shouldn't be a battle
you know you have a a good home you have
a loving home this can't be a battle
between that home and an administration
that is catering to what a child wants
and exiting the parent out because the
parent doesn't abide by their set of
principles shall we say if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]